I feel like there's movement happening
behind me yeah you okay I'm fine
I'm sorry that was why Adam Devine he's
one of the stars of the new movie pitch
perfect 2 which hits theaters this is
max it's right in this face in the
loving way it's the dirty little theater
phases have you seen the film I have I
am actually genuinely really excited
about it because a lot of times I lie
right but now I'm not I'm actually
pumped for it and I think people really
like it
yeah actually like something that you
did yes finally finally you have a raw I
mean really I've done something well I
would like you to do something here for
us I'm gonna name some of the people
from the cast and if you could give me
one word that you would use to describe
that person just free association that
would be great okay yeah okay here we go
Anna Kendrick pint okay I believe it
rebel Wilson bodacious whoa Elizabeth
thanks leader oh and they all start with
AH so it's all a man - branch of it
thank you
okay Brittany Snow fixies using American
Sign Language as well now it's perfect
Adam Devine number on number like 6 to 6
ok
Hailee Steinfeld tall Flula Borg German
Katy Siegel Suns / - / anarchy
/ pitch / perfect / - / mom I love that
word
Reggie Watts talented and then one for
the pitch perfect 2 as a whole super fun
summertime wow that sounds like a Will
Smith's out yeah no it is that's his
unreleased tracks I love Will Smith it's
perfect 3 they're already in talks oh I
was gonna start a Kickstarter for you
but if it's already has you don't have
to already happening thank you for that
make sure you go check out pitch perfect
2 in the
starting Friday May it thank you to make
sure you check out Adam Devine on the
grace Helbig show that happens as well
the grace Helbig show moving to Sunday
May 31st at 11:00